>> Sean: BIG NEWS.
FOX NEWS ALERT.
REPUBLICANS ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE RELEASING THE
INITIAL FINDINGS AFTER THE
COMMITTEE ENDED THIS PART OF
THE RUSE PROBE.
THEY CONCLUDE NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION IN THE
2016 ELECTION.
WE HAVE BEEN LIED TO ALL THIS
TIME.
EARLIER TODAY, PRIOR TO THE
REPORT, I SAT DOWN WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE FOR
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW AND I
ASKED THE VICE PRESIDENT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA REFUSING TO ENFORCE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION LAWS, JOY
BEHAR ATTACKING HIS FAITH AND
MORE.
TAKE A LOOK.
YOU HAVE SANCTUARY CITIES AND
NOW A SANCTUARY STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE PRESIDENT EXPECTED TO GO
TO CALIFORNIA TOMORROW.
THEN YOU HAVE DEFIANT OAKLAND
MAYOR WHO IS TIPPING OFF
ILLEGAL, CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THAT I.C.E. AND
BORDER ARE COMING THEIR WAY.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WENT SO
FAR TO SAY THEY WILL USE EVERY
TOOL THEY HAVE AGAINST THE
OAKLAND MAYOR.
IS THAT A CRIME IN YOUR VIEW?
IS THAT OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE?
>> Vice President Pence: WE
ARE A NATION OF LAWS, SEAN.
ALL OF US TAKE THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO SERVE AT EVERY
LEVEL.
TAKE AN OATH TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND FOR STATE OFFICIALS TO THE
CONSTITUTION OF THAT STATE.
I MEAN TO HAVE AN ELECTIVE
MAYOR IN OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA,
SAYING THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
UPHOLD THE LAW ON THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Sean: WORSE, HELPING
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BROKEN THE
LAW.
>> Vice President Pence:
LOOK, THE MAYOR'S ACTIONS ARE
DISGRACEFUL ON A COUPLE OF
LEVELS.
SHE IS SETTING ASIDE HER OATH
OF OFFICE TO UPHOLD THE LAW OF
THE LAND AND THE RULE OF LAW.
SECONDLY, I SPOKE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT THIS.
THE MAJORITY OF INFORMATIONS
TARGETED -- THE MAJORITY OF
THE INDIVIDUALS TARGETED BY
I.C.E. HAD A CRIMINAL RECORD.
SO FOR THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND TO
WARN THEM IN ADVANCE OF THE
ACTIONS BY I.C.E. PERSONNEL
PUT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AT RISK.
THIS IS UTTERLY UNACCEPTABLE.
WE NEED TO FIX BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
WE NEED TO FIX THE SYSTEM TO
PUT AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
AMERICAN WORKERS FIRST.
WE CAN DO THAT.
THE ANSWER IS NOT THE CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE THAT WE SEE IN
MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENTS AND
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
SIMPLY SAYING WE GOING TO SET
ASIDE A RECOGNITION, FEDERAL
LAW, BECAUSE WE DISAGREE WITH
IT.
WE ASK FOR LEADERS TO RESPECT
THE RULE OF LAW AND PUT THE
SAFETY AND THE SECURITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL FIRST.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE AN
INCIDENT, THE COMMENTS MADE BY
JOY BEHAR OF "THE VIEW" WHERE
SAID SHE CALLED YOU PRIVATELY
TO APOLOGIZE.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED.
SHE DIDN'T SAY IT PUBLICLY.
THE INITIAL COMMENTS WERE MADE
PUBLICLY.
>> MY CHRISTIAN FAITH IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IN MY
LIFE.
MY WIFE AND I SPEND MOST
MORNINGS, A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
ON THE BIBLE AND A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME IN PRAYER.
WE ARE TYPICAL AMERICANS.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
CHERISH THEIR FAITH.
SO, WHEN I HEARD THAT ABC HAD
A PROGRAM WHERE MY CHRISTIAN
FAITH WAS DESCRIBED AS A
MENTAL ILLNESS, I THOUGHT IT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME TO SPEAK
OUT.
NOT ON MY OWN BEHALF.
WE KNOW THE CRITICISM COMES
WITH THE PUBLIC LIFE.
I WANTED TO DEFEND THE FAITH
OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
AGAINST THAT KIND OF SLANDER.
AND I DID SO.
I GIVE JOY A LOT OF CREDIT.
SHE PICKED UP THE PHONE.
SHE CALLED ME.
SHE WAS VERY SINCERE.
AND SHE APOLOGIZED.
ONE OF THE THINGS MY FAITH
TEACHES ME IS GRACE.
FORGIVE AS YOU HAVE BEEN
FORGIVEN.
>> Sean: SO DOES MINE BUT
I'M NOT AS GOOD AS IT AS YOU.
>> Vice President Pence: I
SAID OF COURSE, I FORGIVE YOU.
THAT IS PART OF MY FAITH
EXPERIENCE.
BUT I DID ENCOURAGE HER AND I
AM STILL ENCOURAGING HER TO
USE THE FORM OF THE -- FORUM
OF THAT PROGRAM OR ANOTHER
FORUM TO APOLOGIZE TO TEN OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO WERE
EQUALLY OFFENDED.
>> Sean: SHE MAKES ME
QUESTION THE SINCERITY OF IT.
IT WASN'T JUST A SHOT AGAINST
YOU.
IT WAS AGAINST -- I'M A
CHRISTIAN -- ANYBODY OF FAITH.
>> Vice President Pence: FOR
ME, IT WAS NEVER ABOUT ME.
>> Sean: UNDERSTOOD.
YOU DON'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
>> Vice President Pence: I
DIDN'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT IN
THIS MOMENT THAT I SPEAK OUT
ON BEHALF OF THE FAITH OF TENS
OF MILLIONS OF AMERICANS.
MY HOPE IS THAT JOY AND OTHERS
ON THE AIRWAVES WILL COME TO
APPRECIATE THE MEANING AND, IF
I CAN SAY, THE JOY THAT COMES
WITH THE FAITH AND RESPECT
THAT.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
2018.
WE EXPECTED, THE DEMOCRATS
EXPECTED A BIG BLUE WAVE IN
TEXAS.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
TOMORROW THERE IS AN IMPORTANT
RACE GOING ON IN THE
PENNSYLVANIA 18th
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT.
A LOT OF TURMOIL FOR THE
COUNTRY IF NANCY PELOSI BECAME
THE SPEAKER AGAIN?
>> Vice President Pence: THE
ONLY THING AT STAKE IS
EVERYTHING.
IF YOU LIKE A GROWING ECONOMY,
IF YOU LIKE 3 MILLION NEW
JOBS, IF YOU LIKE A PRESIDENT
REBUILDING THE MILITARY.
STANDING TALL AND THE WORLD
AGAIN.
FIGHTING FOR THE FREE, FAIR
AND RECIPROCAL TRADE TO
APPOINT CONSERVATIVE TO THE
COURT AND CUTTING TAXES WHAT
HAPPENS TOMORROW IS MORE THAN
THE TWO CANDIDATES ON THE
BALLOT.
THE PRESIDENT AND I BOTH
CAMPAIGNED FOR RICK SACCONE.
HE WOULD BE A FANTASTIC MEMBER
OF CONGRESS.
WORE THE UNIFORM OF THE UNITED
STATES FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES.
HE WAS ENDORSED BY THE
"PITTSBURGH POST GAZETTE"
SUNDAY MORNING.
THAT ELECTION TO ME AND THIS
FALL ELECTION ARE MORE ABOUT
THE DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY.
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEND A MESSAGE
THEY SUPPORT THE DIRECTION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Sean: IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
CRUMBS THAT NANCY PELOSI TALKS
ABOUT?
>> Vice President Pence: IT
REALLY IS.
IF THE DEMOCRATS TOOK OVER THE
CONGRESS IN THIS FALL'S
ELECTION NANCY PELOSI WOULD BE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AGAIN.
WE DON'T HAVE TO WONDER WHAT
IT WOULD BE LIKE.
I WAS IN CONGRESS THE LAST
TIME IT HAPPENED.
ALL ABOUT RAISING TAXES AND
MORE REGULATIONS.
THE DODD-FRANK BILL THAT
KILLED COMMUNITY BANKING AND
LENDING TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS.
THEY FORCED OBAMACARE ON THE
COUNTRY.
WE KNOW THEY WOULD WANT TO
TURN BACK THE PROGRESS THE
PRESIDENT MADE.
THAT IS WHY THE PRESIDENT ARE
IN PENNSYLVANIA SATURDAY NIGHT
AND WHY WE WITH CAMPAIGNING
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY TO MAKE
SURE WE RE-ELECT THE MAJORITY
CONSERVATIVES ON CAPITOL HILL
TO PARTNER FROM THE PRESIDENT.